santé une nouvelle étude qui vient
s'ajouter à d'autres déjà nombreuse il y
est question des dangers ou non du
portable
ce rapport britannique démontre lui
l'innocuité des téléphones cellulaires
le mobile n'augmenterait pas le risque
de tumeur du cerveau nicolas chateauneuf
on en compte 45 millions rien qu'en
france les téléphones portables font
désormais partie du quotidien des
français 3 sur 4 ans sont équipés et
pourtant une question reste lancinante
le téléphone portable est il nocif pour
la santé
une étude britannique apporte un nouvel
élément de réponse selon les
responsables usages du mobile n'accroît
pas le risque de tumeur du cerveau
pendant quatre ans les comportements au
téléphone de 966 personnes atteintes de
la tumeur du cerveau la plus fréquente
ont été comparés à ceux de 1716
volontaires en bonne santé résultats il
n'y a aucune différence entre les deux
we found
nous avons démontré que l'usagé du
téléphone portable n'avait pas
d'incidence sur le fait que les gens
développent une tumeur au cerveau dont
la fréquence d'utilisation du court ça
ne vais pas non plus de lien avec ces
tumeurs jusqu'à maintenant aucune étude
n'a fait le lien entre téléphones
portables et problèmes de santé certains
scientifiques mettent en avant les
risques liés à l'utilisation dans des
zones peu couverte à cause de signaux
plus intense
d'autres mettent en garde contre l'usagé
du portable par les enfants dans le
cerveau seraient plus sensibles
mais pour l'instant rien n'est
corroborée cette étude fait partie de la
plus grande enquête jamais lancée sur
les effets du téléphone portable
elle est menée dans 13 pays différents
s'il y met